right now I'm interested in things like
food Transportation housing the stuff
that every person spends a huge
percentage of their paycheck on every
month um if you look at how much value
has been unlocked by things like uber
and Airbnb I think there's opportunities
to to build companies as large as those
um on on other things we spend a lot of
money on on one example is Healthcare um
obviously if you're a consumer of
healthcare you may not have had great
experiences and if you've looked at the
bills you know a lot of money is getting
spent um I think there's an opportunity
to build Uber and Airbnb scale
businesses um attack attacking
healthcare for instance as well as
definitely in
food my advice for people building
content businesses uh having built them
before is to have a clever plan on how
to monetize I think a lot of people
think if they build it people will come
and if they have millions of users they
will magically get rich and it's not
that simple um cpms are going down all
the time and you you have to be working
against that um so if you find
interesting ways to monetize via I don't
know native advertising or directly
being supported by the fans those are
pretty interesting to me and I think
it's worth at least having a plan about
that in the earliest days and not just
assuming you know if you get a million
dollars that VCS will pay for the whole
thing um maybe that worked a while ago
but I don't think that works
anymore so I'm the head of admissions at
y combinator um can so can tell you a
little bit about the process the most
important part about admissions at YC is
filling out an application uh sometimes
people think they have to know us or
network with us to get in and that's not
true the vast vast majority of people
that get into YC are just rers that fill
out an
application um the top a top percentile
of the folks that uh fill out an
application are invited for an in-person
interview with us and that's where we
get to know you a little bit more um a
lot of times people email us and almost
like ask for permission before they
decide to put an application and my
advice to anybody that's interested in
YC is just to just do the application um
so much of startups just is just doing
the thing you're thinking about doing
and not looking for permission uh from
people before doing it so if you're
interested you should just
apply I think the null hypothesis is
that um things won't change and the the
music industry is just inherently going
to be smaller forever that the fact it
was as big as it was was a fluke of
History um physical media was a very
good business and because we don't have
physical media anymore it may be that
there's no way to replace the revenue
that will make it the size that it once
was and that's okay I think there's
several other industries that were U
that have gotten smaller with technology
as they moved to Pure digital and it
could just be that the size of
opportunity in music um will never
recover and that's okay um so I don't
think we should assume that one day the
time will be right when that's the day
to start starting music startups again
if I were on the team that was working
on whale um I think the biggest thing
that I would be thinking about is less
here are our metrics and here's how
we're tracking them and let's just grow
x% week over week I'd be more looking at
the data to figure
out what it is and sort of
existentially why do people want this
why do they want to use it and make sure
that this is a thing um like is this the
next is this a quora competitor is this
um some kind of Q&A app for your friends
is this for tech people is this for
celebrities I think I'd be looking at
all of the early data and try to get a
sense of what my gut told me as a
Founder the future of the product is and
only then look at the metrics and make
sure I'm growing in that specific um in
that specific vertical or use case
because if you're just blindly looking
at growth and you don't have a vision
for the product you could get
lost I was a Founder for a very long
time um way longer than I've been
working in YC and I raised I think eight
or nine rounds of funding over the coast
on my career and so I can really relate
to what it's like being on that side of
the table and I would say one of the big
things I've learned is how many
decisions that investors make that are
not personal
um I remember sometimes worrying if you
know maybe someone was passing on my
company because they didn't like me or
they didn't you know that it was somehow
personal to me and what I realized being
on this side of the table is it's not
and I think my message um if I was going
to start another company and to the
people out there is to remember how
unimportant doing things like networking
and feeling like you're you're well
connected to investors matter and that
if you have a good company with good
numbers if you have a great product um
that's what's going to make people fund
you way more than trying to influence
them and network with them
um all right cold emailing investors
what do I think about that two things
one of all of the ways you can spend
your time as a founder of all the ways
you can add value to your startup cold
emailing investors should be like those
lowest priority for every hour you spend
on that hopefully you've spent about a
thousand hours working on your startup
itself writing code getting customers um
a lot of people spend way too much time
talking to investors and not nearly
enough on their
startup Point number two um the whole
reason why combinator exists and we have
an application process is that you can
just apply you don't need to know us if
you try to cold email us we just tell
you to go to our website and apply um
so really no need to email anyone in the
YC ecosystem just go to our website and
apply
thanks Kanye West for
president um here's what I think I was
actually at the Kanye show that happened
in San Jose um right as the Meltdown was
starting he played a couple of songs and
this just completely stopped playing any
songs and talked to the audience for not
exaggerating for something like an hour
and he was just talking about Trump he
was talking about how he respects Trump
how he if he would have voted would have
voted for Trump and I saw all this stuff
in person and I think to him it was so
crazy to see someone like Trump elected
that it doesn't sound far-fetched that
someone like Kanye could be elected and
you know what um I don't think he's
wrong
most of the time a good startup um or a
startup that's in YC uh can build the
entire product do sales do everything
they need to do with just the founders
the founders between themselves have the
ability to execute and so they don't
have employees um so most of the time um
I would suggest not hiring a founding
team at all and only um start to hire
when the company is going so well that
that's your bottleneck and usually
that's after YC for a lot of folks um
months after YC and so whether or not
you end up in Mountain View or moving
somewhere else um that's kind of up to
you but the short version is if you're
thinking about hiring very early in the
process it's usually a sign that uh you
may want to add some more skills to your
founding
team there's a lot of variability on
what makes a good YC application and I
would never want to put out advice that
would cause everyone to try to make
their application look a certain way but
what I would say
um one underlying quality you see across
the board is Clarity of communication
where the description of what are we
doing why are we doing it why are we the
team to do it what are our insights
they're able to State those things very
clearly and Clarity of thought in the
part of the founder and Clarity of
communication
um are very predictive of a company
being able to get an interview as well
as getting into YC and even after YC
it's a it's a good predictor of the
company uh will be able to work if
they're good at
communication what I've learned about
failure working at Y combinator is that
um most of the time the vast majority of
the time it's not a big bang it's not
something dramatic that happens it's
just finally you capitulate finally you
decide to give up you decide to go get a
job and that um failure is is pretty
normal and it's not the big crazy boom
that you would
expect and sort of what I learn and and
the way I think about this is that
failure is if we think about the
scientific method failure is the null
hypothesis the null hypothesis is that
this didn't work and that you should
assume by default that's what's going to
happen and it's your job with the time
that you're given to prove otherwise
otherwise um the null hypothesis is
true as far as the why now question on
the YC application I actually think
you're uh misunderstanding it the reason
it's there is why is this the perfect
time to start the startup if you would
have tried to start Uber before the
iPhone
it wouldn't have worked and I'm pretty
sure people did um instacart was an idea
that was tried during the com boom with
web van and others and failed pretty
badly for a variety of reasons but the
time instacart started was exactly the
right time to start instacart and so
what we're looking for to answer on the
question why now is what is happening in
the world what are the other factors
that make this the perfect moment in
time not too early or not too late to
start the start of
um that you're working
on repeat applicants have um actually a
pretty good chance of getting in I don't
know if everyone realizes this but um a
pretty decent percentage of a batch is
people that we had previously uh not
accepted and they came back and then you
know the next time or two batches later
we took them
um my advice is to make sure that you're
making progress nothing is more exciting
than to see someone have an idea that's
really early uh be unlaunched and then
apply again next batch and they're
launched and they have customers um or
they have Revenue the more you can show
that your idea is working and you're
making true progress and not fake
progress um the the more likely it is
you'll be able to to get in the next
time around and you know it's super
impressive to see someone come back next
batch and and the the business is in
such a different state you know the
founders are working really hard on it
and making tons of progress and so we'd
love we'd love to interview
those the biggest wild card for knowing
uh if you have a good chance to get into
YC it's actually team questions and I
know it's hard to talk about your team
and the context of this uh whale
question but um who you are who on the
team is technical how long have you
known each other what are your insights
on the product those are those are
honestly the most important criteria
that we're looking for in a company
um unlike a later stage investor where
you would have growth Milestones or
Revenue Milestones um we're much more
focused on on the team aspects than than
hard specific numbers that I could give
you guidance
on there's this uh really common thing
in Silicon Valley
where after a startup is successful a
bunch of stories and myths are created
um to sort of imply that was their
mission all along and I think in the
case of Google um there's no way in the
first few years of the company they said
that their goal was to organize and make
accessible the world's information that
was that was like a mission statement
that came much later I think in the
earliest days um it came out of research
they were doing at Stanford they had a
clever hack um by looking at backlinks
to determine the how authoritative a
website is and it ended up being a
really good hack they wrote papers about
it they didn't want to start a company
they tried to sell the technology they
weren't able to to sell the technology
and then they end up starting Google and
the real story to me is a lot more
indicative of what the future of uh you
know building a Google competitor other
ways to make knowledge competitive uh
accessible is is people will just fall
into it it'll be happening on
accident the best way to talk about what
your insights are is to tell tell the
story tell The Narrative of here's what
our initial idea is here's how we talk
to users here's how we experimented it
uh with it in the market and then here's
what we learned um here's something that
happened as a result of user feedback
because often the best insights are
things that were an accident or
something unexpected that happened by
you trying it um insights that are
gained that way are always way better
than ones of just hey I read a book
about this and I got an Insight um you
know a good Insight is something that
you yourself has that someone else that
hasn't actually tried to do the thing um
would not would have not figured out on
their own